Well,
what I'm worried about also
in this age of social media,
I've noticed as a,
as a teacher in the classroom,
that the young people are so used
to communicating now by cell phone,
okay.
Buy iPhone,
um,
that they're losing body
language and facial expressions.
Okay.
Which I think is going to compound the
problem with these dating encounters.
Okay.
Because the ability to read
the human face and into,
into,
into read little tiny
inflections of emotion.
I think my generation got that from
looking at great foreign films with,
with our,
with our long takes,
cause you'd have drawn
Moreau and FM to nerves.
Okay.
And like a potential romantic encounters.
And you could usually see the tiniest
little little inflections that signal
communication or sexual readiness or,
or irony or skepticism
or distance or whatever.
But the inability to read the other
people's intentions that I think this is
going to be a disaster.
I mean I just noticed that,
um,
how year by year.
Okay.
The students are becoming
much more flat affect.
Okay.
And they themselves complained that
they'll sit in the same room with someone
and be texting to each other.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well there's a,
there's a piece of evidence to
that supports that to some degree.
So women with brothers are
less likely to get raped.
And the reason for that is that they've
learned that nonverbal language deeply.
Right.
And they can,
they can,
they can spot the,
I have,
I have noticed,
okay.
Uh,
in my,
in my career,
okay.
That,
that women who have many brothers okay.
Are very good.
Okay.
As administrators and as business people.
All right.
Because they don't take men seriously.
Okay.
They regard,
they,
they saw their brothers,
they think they're brothers aren't jokes.
Okay.
But they know how to control men.
While it,
while they still like men.
Okay.
They admire men.
Right.
So this is something I
have seen repeatedly.
There will be also reflective of the
problem of fewer and fewer siblings.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
And I've noticed this in publishing.
Okay.
That,
that the,
um,
the,
the women who have job,
the job of publicist,
okay.
And writes the Topis as
manager of publicity.
Okay.
Their ability to take charge of men and,
and the,
and their humor at men,
they,
and,
and in,
and they have great relationships with
men because they don't have the sense of
resentment in an,
in,
in worry and anxiety.
And so they don't see men as aggressors.
Okay.
And I think that's another thing too,
is that as feminism,
um,
you know,
uh,
moved into his presence,
it's a system of videology.
Okay.
It has tended to,
uh,
denigrate motherhood.
Okay.
As a lesser order of human
experience and to enshrine,
of course,
abortion.
I am 100% of abortion rights.
You know,
I belong to planned parenthood for
years until I finally rejected it as on
branch or the Democratic Party,
my own party and so on.
Um,
but,
but as became excluded as s
feminists and became obsessed okay.
With the,
with,
with the work with a professional woman.
Okay.
I feel that the lessons are that
mothers learn had been lost.
Okay.
Yeah.
Two,
two,
two feminism.
Okay.
Which is okay if the,
the mothers who,
who bear boy children.
Okay.
Understand the fragility of men,
the fragility and boys,
they understand it.
They don't,
they don't seem them.
Men,
boys and men as a menace.
They understand the
greater strength of women.
Okay.
So there's this tenderness
and connectedness between the,
between the mother and the boy child.
Okay.
When motherhood is part of the experience.
I'll have women who are discussing gender.
So he didn't,
it was all we have today
is that this does gender.
The LG has risen up on
campuses where we're all,
none of the,
none of the girls know.
The students have married,
none of them had children.
Okay.
And you have,
you have women.
Some of them have had children,
but a lot of them are lesbians or like,
or like are you on or like
professional women and so on.
So this,
this the whole tenderness and forgiving,
forgiving us.
Okay.
And encouragement that
women do to two boys.
Okay.
The fringes,
they don't understand this
hypersensitivity of boys.
It's not understood.
Okay.
Instead button,
boys are seen as somehow
a more privileged.
Okay.
And somehow,
you know,
their,
their energy level is,
is interpreted as aggression.
Okay.
Potential violence and so on.
All right.
Uh,
so I think that that the,
that what we would do the better.
Okay.
If we would have,
I have proposed,
okay.
That colleges should allow when the
moment a woman has entered has entered.
Okay.
She has entrusted in
that college for life.
Okay.
And that she,
that she should be free to leave.
Okay.
To have babies when she,
when her body wants them babies,
when it's healthy to have no.
Okay.
And then return have,
haven't had the occasional course so it
can build up credits and father's going
to be,
you might be able to do it as it as
well and so on to get married women,
women with children into the classroom.
The moment that happens and it's
happened after World War Two.
Okay.
We've had,
he had a lot of married you
guys in the classroom and so on.
Not yet.
And it's not that many women,
the experience of a married
person with a family.
Okay.
Talking about gender,
but most of the gender stuff
would be laughed out of the room.
Okay.
If you had a real mother in there who
had experienced in child birth and had it
had rained and it was
raising boys and so on.
So I think that that's also,
uh,
you know,
something that has led to this,
this,
this incredible art,
you know,
artificiality and,
uh,
and hysteria.
Okay.
Feminist rhetoric.